actress sofia boutella might seem like a
newcomer whether eerie turn as princess
AMA Nats in the 2017 rebooted The Mummy
launching her into the Hollywood
mainstream but the Algerian French
actress has actually been working her
way into the limelight for years and has
amassed a number of credits that may
make her face familiar to Mummy watchers
across the world here's where you might
have seen botella before those Nike ads
boot Alice started her career in the
arts as a dancer and was known for her
choreography skills particularly in the
hip hop genre she achieved a commercial
breakthrough in the mid arts when she
starred in a series of make yourself
themed advertisements for Nike that
exposure would wind up landing her back
up dancing gigs with artists like
Madonna who kept her touring for the
better part of a decade and then I
started dancing with her and and and she
gave me a pair of heels for the first
time asking me if I were advanced in
heels and I said no and she was a
beginning for everything Michael Jackson
who Tellez work with Madonna brought her
to the attention of the biggest pop star
in the world Michael Jackson who offered
her a chance to star in his this is it
concert series
she told dancing times I spoke to
Jackson on the phone he called me he
said you're an amazing dancer god bless
you I really want you on my show and I
said I will do my best then I was on the
phone to his stage director Kenny Ortega
and he told me when you're done with
Madonna come and join us and I said okay
I will and then he passed although she
never got the chance to share the stage
with the King of Pop she did have the
chance to collaborate with the singer
posthumously when she starred as the
lead in the music video for his single
Hollywood tonight Street Dance 2 in 2012
buuut ella made the jump to movies with
the film street dance - she plated the
answer named diva who specializes in the
tango and salsa something boot ella
didn't have much experience with but she
still felt a kindred spirit with her
character she told all street dance eva
is a Latin dancer and she is totally
abandoning herself with those hip-hop
dancers she is giving herself this
chance for this alternative to learn
something else to learn something that
is completely different and give herself
to this world that she's not used to and
she's taking risks I think this is
something I can recognize it myself
not with hip-hop or Latin dance but with
life I see things and I want to go there
even if it costs something because
you're letting go of something that you
know so much indeed lute ella would
eventually set aside her ambitions as a
dancer to pursue her screen career
Kingsman the Secret Service in Matthew
Vaughn's 2014 hit Kingsman the Secret
Service who Telus starred as gazelle a
role that was originally written for a
man but when Vaughn got a look at boo
Tellez Nike ads he decided to redesign
the characters so I thought you know
what we could play this quite sexy and
stylish and if you've got blaze like
that you don't have to be strong you
just have to be agile and precise which
she was Kingsman was boo Tellez first
big Hollywood production and experience
she described is surreal when I arrived
and I see Sam Jackson and Mark Hamill
here and unsetting was my first day of
shooting I I couldn't believe I was
there but I had to focus and do all the
work you know Star Trek beyond in the
2016 sci-fi blockbuster Star Trek beyond
the third installment to the rebooted
Star Trek film series loot ella starred
as Jayla character that was famously
inspired by Jennifer Lawrence
although boot ella would hardly be
recognizable beneath her thick facial
prosthetics she'd make a more
personality oriented mark on the
characters development Jayla has this
sense of innocence but also this quality
of strength that is not manufactured
buuut Ellis choreography skills came in
handy during her mini fight scenes
earning her the respect of co-stars like
Simon Pegg who described her as the real
deal comes from very strong race of
aliens physically extremely strong she's
incredibly tough independent resourceful
you help me and I help you
atomic blonde film stardom may not have
been her first ambition but sofia
boutella is moving at warp speed now in
addition to landing a pivotal role in
the mummy she also snagged the part of a
French spy named Elfie in the action
flick atomic blonde opposite Oscar
winner Charlize Theron patella described
her love scenes with Theron is very
technical telling USA Today it's not as
glamorous as you think you want it all
to translate in the film so that it's
very hot and steamy
Vitelli atomic blonde work should only
increase her exposure to a quickly
growing audience and without requiring
her to reek undead havoc too while her
mummy character is a core component of
universals dark universe sofia boutella
star looks nothing but bright thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to the YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]